(whimsical music)
- [Host] Over two billion
cups of coffee are consumed
every day, and it take a lot
of people to make just one cup.
One man went on a quest to
figure out what it's like
to thank each and every one of them.
A.J. Jacobs is a writer
who lives in New York City.
- Hi, I'm A.J.
- [Host] And he's the first to admit
he can be a bit of a grouch.
- [A.J.] My default state is grumpiness.
I am very good at noticing
all the things that go wrong.
- [Host] So to make a change,
he started giving thanks
during dinner.
- [A.J.] I would say thank you to everyone
who helped make my meal.
- [Host] Until one night.
- [A.J.] My 10-year old son
was like, you know, Dad,
those people can't hear you.
If you really cared,
you would go and thank
these people in person.
And that's when the light bulb went off.
- [Host] He decided to
hone in on something
he knew he took for granted every day:
- [A.J.] My morning cup of coffee.
- [Host] Over the next 12 months,
A.J. set out to thank every
single person who had even
the smallest role in
his morning cup of joe.
First, it was his local barista,
the roaster, and the coffee shop sourcer.
- [A.J.] Whenever I thanked one person,
they would say, "Well,
I couldn't do my job
"without this person."
So one person led to
another, led to another,
led to another.
- [Host] He ventured outside the city,
and eventually the country.
- [A.J.] I thanked the folks
who provide electricity
to the coffee shop, the
engineers who provide the water,
the people who make the steel, the farmer
and the importer, the truck driver,
the person who paved the road,
even the woman who painted
the yellow lines in the road
so that my coffee beans
could safely arrive
at my coffee shop.
I remember, I called the
woman who does pest control
for the warehouse, and I said,
"I know this sounds strange,
"but I want to thank you
for keeping the insects
"out of my coffee."
And she said, "Well,
that does sound strange,
"but, thank you."
You know, I don't get a lot
of appreciation in my job.
- [Host] All in, A.J. ended
up thanking over 1,000
different people, and while
most were pleasantly surprised
by his gratitude, it's A.J.
who benefited the most.
- [A.J.] The experience
has made me grateful
for the hundreds of things
that go right every day
as opposed to the three
or four that go wrong.
I tell my friends that they should try
these gratitude trails themselves.
They could just be small gestures,
looking someone in the eye,
the cashier at the drugstore.
It could be sending a
quick note to the designer
of a logo you love.
I will tell you that it
will make your life better.
It's changed the way I live my life.
(glittering flourish)